no more Stargate that is the headline on
a gateworld video that we released a
couple of days ago but is Stargate
really dead
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
welcome to the sunny North Wales where I
am going to do a quick little video very
short talking about why we should be
confident that Stargate is going to
return if you are a regular snap tracker
you know that I'm pretty confident this
is going to be coming back and that
we're going to be hearing something in
the new year
but there are a couple of points which
is consider to give us a little bit more
confidence and to not worry about the
pessimism of channels like gateworld now
gate world's incredibly loyal to Brad
right they have been pushing for Brad
Wright's script from the moment they
heard about it they do lots of
interviews with the Stars and things and
obviously they are close to the source
but for me
I think if they bring in new blood I
don't have a problem with that and I'm
looking forward to whatever project
Amazon bring on if it's crap I'll be the
first one to tell you but I'm not going
to stress about it in the meantime if
it's not Brad right I'm just going to
look forward to whatever comes out and I
am confident even if I take out the
rumors that I've been hearing about
[ __ ] Coast being Mark Fergus developing
a new series and all the stuff I'm
hearing about from sources that I speak
to there are real world things you can
look at that if you read between the
lines does make it look more likely this
target is going to return for example
Brad Wright's words himself talking
about how Stargate is not going to get
made by him now and his script is
virtually dead in the water why release
those statements now now I've spoken to
One Source Who said in his opinion and
it's just his opinion but he is an
expert in the industry so he does know
these things but in his opinion he
thinks those statements have been
released by Brad Wright saying how his
script is not going to get made and how
he's not involved in a new Stargate is
simply because he isn't involved in new
Stargate but he knows new Stargate is
coming so he's trying to maybe prepare
fans for that disappointment a little
bit but at the same time removing
himself from the Stargate project for
when it does get announced because when
it does he is going to be flooded with
messages from the fans particularly
asking him if he's involved or why isn't
he involved so he's preparing us for
that fact now but also just go and have
a look at any news report that mentions
anything to do with Amazon or GM there
was one just over a week ago talking
about how Amazon are about to invest
over a billion dollars in straight to
cinema movies in the next year
in that it talks about the acquisition
of MGM and how probably a lot of those
movies that Amazon are going to be
spending all that money on will be
produced by MGM but then as part of the
story it does talk about MGM and how
Amazon bought MGM for the intellectual
properties it then mentioned some of
those intellectual properties and the
three that they decided to mention in
the story Rocky we have a sequel of that
coming in probably a reboot
James Bond obviously and Stargate now
this is something I told you well over a
year ago to expect that just before any
new Stargate was released we would start
seeing lots of stories in the media
mentioning Stargate now we've seen quite
a few in like variety and a couple of
other places just talking about why
isn't there a Stargate why isn't there a
Stargate but then also for it to get
mentioned in news reports like this
it's very telling so guys if you're
starting to panic and start to wonder
where is my Stargate and starting to
stress that maybe it isn't going to
happen and I'll tell you I'll be honest
I've Had My Moments myself I've had
moments where I'm thinking this isn't
going to happen
Ollie's rumors and things I'm hearing
you know they might turn into nothing
but
the more I read and the more I see and
the more I have to read between the
lines the more confident I am that we
are going to be hearing something really
amazing and really official
really soon so stay confident keep your
chins up Gators we will be getting new
Stargate very soon and hopefully Amazon
won't [ __ ] it up if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
and if you want to become a fully
fledged side tracker and support the
channel even more consider hitting the
join Button as always stay safe stay
sunny and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]